The power dynamics of the One piece world have
just completely been flipped on its head. With the
official release of chapter 1053, we finally know
how the government has assessed the events that
happened during the raid on Onigashima on Wano.
Big news Morgan and the Gorosei have sat down,
cranked the numbers and updated a whole number of
bounties for everyone involved in the battle. The
three captains, Luffy, Law and Kid, all have
received a massive increase to their wanted
posters, each of them now sitting at a staggering
3 billion berries. At first glance, that might
seem a bit low, given that both Big Mom and Kaido
had bounties well over 4 billion, but remember
that Blackbeards bounty is only 2.2 billion. So
all three of them just overtook the possibly most
dangerous pirate on the planet. Also, it of course
follows the really nice pattern of 3, that Luffy
has followed throughout the story. 30M, 300M and
now 3 B berries. Even if you expected a bit more,
I just want to appreciate that Luffy and
co now have the 4th highest known bounty
in the entire story, given that Kaido and Big
Mom presumably don't have a bounty anymore,
because they fell into a volcano and apparently
that's just that. So now we have 3 members of
the worst generation, that was looked upon as
just a group of rookies only 2 years earlier,
throning at the peak of the pirate world.
And yet somehow even more shockingly, the goose
have also identified the two official replacements
for both Kaido and Big Mom for the title of the
four most powerful pirates in all of One PIece,
the Yonko. The last remaining member of the
original 4 is shanks, who with his 4billion berry
bounty is now officially the most wanted pirate in
the world, probably only topped by the head of the
revolutionary army, Monkey D. Dragon. It's not
like we need any more intrigue for Shanks. He's
already the one character in the story
every single fan, including me is just
dying to learn more about. But it
definitely helps to push the mystery.
And funnily enough all 4 current YOnko have a
personal connection to shanks for some reason.
The next in line is Blackbeard, who has
been an emperor since the marineford war
and who tirelessly keeps increasing
his power and influence in the world.
Blackbeard without any doubt has been built
up as one of the major final antagonists,
if not THE final antagonist that Luffy will
have to face to actually reach his goal
and become pirate king. We have seen
surprisingly little of his actual abilities,
but just the little we know about him and his
crew is already enough to let us know what an
incredibly powerful enemy he will be for Luffy
and the other straw hats. Blackbeard rose into
the ranks of the Yonko after taking out Whitebeard
at marineford and literally taking his place.
Which is absolutely ironic and hilarious,
because that was literally Buggy's idea when
he was escaping impel down together with
luffy and the other level 6 prisoners. He
literally dreams of becoming an
emperor and then pirate king.
What seemed like gag moment for his
character has now for whatever reason
actually turned out to be true. I'm still
trying to get over this. And honestly it will
probably take a while to get used to. Buggy the
clown, emperor of the seas. Holy moly. However,
in retrospect, when we look at the great scheme
of things, it does truly feel like Eiichiro Oda,
the author of one piece was working towards
this for a while now. Ever since impel down,
Buggy has been constantly getting more and more
influence and recognition by pure accident really,
recruiting some of the most powerful and notorious
pirates to his cause and even rising into the
ranks of the warlords. Of course you could joke
that Buggy might have been doing this all on
purpose all along and it wasn'T luck at all. And
honestly, At this point this is a real possibility
given the circumstances. We don't really know
how he got the position or high his bounty is,
but there are a ton of interesting possibilities
I have floating around my head. I will definitely
dedicate and entire video to Emperor buggy in the
next one or two weeks. So make sure to subscribe
if you want to see that. You'll also help me to
increase my bounty by 100Berry by subscribing,
which is super important, because we might not
know Buggy's bounty yet, but we know that of this
slime ball here, Trebol, with 99M berries. And I'M
only at 60m. So let's go and at least beat Trebol.
The 4th emperor on the other hand, has a bounty
SO high now, that I will never be able to catch up
in my wildest dreams. Luffy had unofficially been
named 5th emperor of the see by Big News Morgan
after escaping Whole Cake Island and defeating
Katakuri. Now, after not only having beaten Kaido,
the worlds strongest creature, but also having
awakened a mythical Zoan Devil Fruit that the
World Government has been fearing for 800
years, it's no big surprise, that he has
officially been named Yonko and thus has reached
the last step before becoming pirate king.
On top of all this, we have just witnessed
Greenbull's terrifying abilities, who is said
to be on the same level as Fujitora. The marines
clearly have made up for the loss of Aokiji and
Sengoku. And of course we still haven't seen the
results of the SSG, the special science group led
by doctor vegapunk, that seems to be more than
capable of replacing the former warlord system.
It must be truly terrifying indeed.
So the span of just a few weeks, the entire
world order has fundamentally changed. It used
to be a relatively stable balance between the 4
emperors, all careful to mess with each other,
the 7 warlords, who were strong pirates
aligned with the government, as well as the
marines. Over the course of Wano, the warlord
system has been abolished, Two of the YOnko
have fallen and replaced and the revolutionary
army has successfully infiltrated the holy land
of Marijois during the reverie. We have learned
about the true secret ruler of the world, Imu,
who controls the entire world government, have
seen Shanks talk with the Gorosei and have
witnessed Luffy's immensely powerful awakening and
the return of Joy Boy and the drums of liberation.
I think it's pretty fair to say, that the one
piece world now and the one piece world at the
beginning of the story are very different indeed.
Gone is the stability of Whiteboards Era. The
Government is building military force like never
before, the revolutionaries have begun to openly
attack the celestial dragons, Black beard has
broken all rules of devil fruit use and power
balance and Luffy, who used to be a upcoming small
fry in a giant world filled with powerful people,
is now one of the handful of selected people
in the world, powerful enough to shape the
future of the entire planet and all of it's
inhabitants. No wonder really One Piece is
about to move into its final saga, if I look at
it from this perspective. Oh, and then there is
of course also Buggy, the biggest wild card of
them all, that now it seems will be playing a
much more central role during the ending of
One Piece, than we all originally expected.
I think while it's really easy to focus
on Luffy's growth, and don't get me wrong,
saying it was rapid would be the understatement
of the century, we should not forget, that all
other players in the endgame here have been
getting stronger and more influential as well.
Blackbeard just keeps collecting more and
more powerful devil fruits and crew members.
Shanks is doing his super special secret
mission impossible plan behind the scenes,
and the government and the marines seem even more
well equipped and all powerful than ever before.
Chapter 1053 also hinted at the reveal of
Pluton, that apparently is located in Wano.
Something Robbin has known all along but
somehow decided not to share with anyone.
Thanks for nothing Robin. Wether Pluton
will turn out to be an actual weapon
or simply Momonosuke, the heir of the Kozuki
clan, similar to how Shirahoshi is Poseidon,
once the ancient weapons unleash their true
powers, they will just add to the already
over boiling pot of fast approaching conflict,
brewing all over the new world right now.
In a really ironic way, the new
world order in One Piece doesn't
really deserve that name. Because all
individuals involved, Blackbeard, Buggy,
Luffy, Kid, Law, even someone like Greenbull, they
are all people who seem to bring about the exact
opposite of order. This new system is a world of
chaos, that is ready to be fundamentally changed,
so that pirates and marines and Yonkos will not
even be a thing anymore. We're in the face now,
where Luffy will have the ability to change the
world, bring the dawn and create a world where
everyone is free to be who they are and do what
they want to do and live a happy and safe life.
After all we now know that this is Luffy's
actually dream. Becoming pirate king so he can
create this free world for his friends. We do NOT
know however what everyone else wants. Imu and the
Gorosei want to stay in power and Buggy presumably
still just wants to find a massive pile of gold,
but we don't know what Blackbeards ultimate goal
is, or shanks or Kid or even many of the admirals.
All of this really seems to be
massive set up for some of the
best fights and meeting we
have seen in one piece so far.
The one I personally look forward to the most is
actually that between Luffy and Blackbeard for
obvious reasons. But there are a number of
other meetings that are basically guaranteed
to happen as well. Oda has come up
with an ingenious idea to foreshadow
big battles and unresolved conflicts in
the story in the most unusual way ever,
by giving characters their iconic scars. So if
you want to find out what Luffy and co's scars
predict for the future of one piece, you
should really watch this video right here.